[Música]
un objeto Volador no identificado fue
derribado este sábado sobre cielos de
Canadá es el segundo objeto de este tipo
de derribado en dos días sobre
territorio norteamericano la ministra de
defensa de Canadá informó que aún no
puede especular sobre el origen del
mismo e informó que se trata de un
objeto cilíndrico más pequeño que el
globo chino derribado la semana pasada
en las costas de Carolina del Norte
el presidente de México Andrés Manuel
López Obrador recibió a su homólogo
cubano Miguel díaz-canel hablaron de
fortalecer la cooperación bilateral
entre ambos países y López Obrador se
reiteró en su ya como un crítica al
embargo estadounidense hacia la isla
ampliamos desde Ciudad de México
este domingo se juega el Super Bowl la
gran final del fútbol americano en
Estados Unidos un evento que mezcla lo
deportivo lo musical y lo comercial el
show de Rihanna en el descanso será uno
de los principales reclamos para los más
de 100 millones de espectadores en todo
el mundo
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos este Informativo en
Canadá el gobierno del país anunció el
derribo de un objeto no identificado que
sobrevolaba el espacio aéreo sobre el
territorio canadiense de Yukon fueron
aviones de combate del Comando
norteamericano de defensa aeroespacial
el noraz formado por Estados Unidos y
Canadá los que derribaron el objeto y
ahora se encargarán de recoger los
restos y analizarlos es el segundo
objeto Volador no identificado derribado
sobre cielo norteamericano en dos días
pocas jornadas después del avistamiento
de dos globos espías chinos sobre los
cielos de Norteamérica y de Suramérica y
el posterior derribo de uno de ellos En
Estados Unidos la Casa Blanca dijo que
el objeto derribado ayer no estaba
relacionado con los Globos chinos la
ministra de defensa canadiense Anita
nant confirmó que se trataba de un
objeto cilíndrico que están analizando y
por el que no motivo de preocupación
para la seguridad de Estados Unidos y
Canadá escuchemos
Aparentemente es un objeto cilíndrico y
estamos trabajando para identificar los
restos Parece ser más pequeño que el que
derribó Estados Unidos en las costas de
Carolina del Sur La semana pasada
hasta donde sabemos esta fue la primera
vez que una operación de norat derribó
un objeto aéreo el objeto volaba a una
altitud de aproximadamente 12 km había
ingresado ilegalmente al espacio aéreo
canadiense y representaba una amenaza
razonable para la seguridad de un vuelo
civil
to the safety el objeto fue derribado
Aproximadamente a 160 kilómetros de la
frontera entre Canadá y Estados Unidos
sobre territorio canadiense en el centro
de yukón
el presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel
López Obrador recibió a su homólogo
cubano Miguel Díaz canel los mandatarios
sostuvieron un en el que resaltaron las
estrechas relaciones entre sus naciones
y el interés mutuo en fortalecer la
cooperación bilateral en medio del
encuentro López Obrador criticó a
Estados Unidos asegurando que debería
levantar cuanto antes el embargo a la
isla que calificó de Injusto e inhumano
nuestro corresponsal en México Mario
carbonell nos contaba los detalles de
esta reunión llena de elogios entre
ambos países
Así es fue un encuentro lleno de
referencias históricas el presidente
Díaz Canelo evocó el paso por México del
libertador José Martí también el paso de
Raúl y de Fidel Castro y del Che Guevara
también refirió el apoyo del presidente
Lázaro Cárdenas durante la invasión a
playa Girón mientras que López Obrador
dijo que mientras aquí durante 30 años
las políticas neoliberales desmantelaron
los servicios de salud dijo que en Cuba
Fidel Castro fue un gran visionario lo
calificó como un hombre de nación como
un gigante al que le rindió homenaje por
haber consolidado Dijo uno de los
sistemas de salud más importantes del
mundo de igual manera López Obrador dijo
que ofrecía que su gobierno va a
encabezar un movimiento mucho más activo
para exigir que se elimine el bloqueo
económico a Cuba dijo que aunque los
conservadores no lo quieran Cuba no
puede estar en la lista de países que
fomentan el terrorismo y dijo que el
gobierno mexicano va a apoyar a que se
respete la independencia y la soberanía
del pueblo cubano en la comuna de walkie
dentro de la región chilena del bío bío
un avión se estrelló en plenos trabajos
de extinción de los más de 300 juegos
que aún siguen activos en el país el
piloto sobrevivió al impacto desde la
zona del accidente nos reportaba
anteriormente nuestra enviada especial
Patricia Luna en chile se cumplen 10
días desde el comienzo de los juegos que
asolan en el centro sur del país y que
comienzan a trasladarse a otras regiones
más centrales en esta jornada se
combatieron más de 300 incendios 94 de
ellos especialmente activos las
condiciones fueron favorables también
para el vuelo de los distintos aviones y
de los helicópteros que en la comuna de
walkie donde nos encontramos fueron
constantes y se han escuchado de forma
continua y los hemos visto también a lo
largo de toda la jornada para combatir
los distintos focos son múltiples los
que se han visto aquí en esta jornada de
hoy con una humarada constante una mala
noticia es que una avioneta de
reconocimiento de la corporación
nacional forestal tuvo un accidente la
pueden ver a nuestras espaldas sin
embargo el piloto resultó ileso pudo
salir por su propio pie se encuentra en
reconocimiento médico pero fuera de
riesgo vital fue ayudado por vecinos De
esta zona que el miércoles pasado vieron
destruidas completamente por el fuego
sus viviendas son parte de esas 1.250
viviendas que han sido completamente
destruidas por el fuego el balance habla
también de casi 2.700 personas
lesionadas más de dos decenas de
fallecidos las autoridades tuvieron un
reconocimiento para el piloto la
ministra del interior Carolina tojah
empezaba su informe diario refiriéndose
a él y también a todas las personas
Agradeciendo a todas las personas que
combaten los fuegos y que arriesgan su
vida en esa lucha contra las llamas
entre ellos los 600 brigadistas llegados
desde distintas partes del globo también
de toda la región para la ayuda contra
los incendios en el gobierno por su
parte comienza la tarea de
reconstrucción se han empezado se van a
iniciar en esta semana la construcción
de viviendas de emergencias en aquellas
zonas donde los focos sean más
controlados este domingo se celebrará el
Super Bowl la gran final del fútbol
americano en Estados Unidos este año se
enfrentarán los Eagles de Filadelfia
contra los chips de Kansas City un
evento que va más allá de lo deportivo y
que contará con más de 100 millones de
espectadores en todo el mundo muchos
esperarán ver el show de la cantante
Rihanna en el descanso del medio tiempo
con este evento aumentará drásticamente
la demanda de aguacates que los
espectadores comen en forma de guacamole
sin embargo en Colombia la producción
creciente de aguacate divide a los
agricultores y amenaza el medio ambiente
Gabriel colchón nos cuenta más
José es uno de los pocos agricultores de
pijao en el departamento del Quindío que
sigue negándose a cultivar aguacates de
hecho acusa a sus vecinos de haber
provocado inundaciones en sus cultivos
de café debido a las altas cantidades de
agua que se utilizan en los campos de
aguacates cercanos el trabajo de toda la
vida 20 años de trabajo que estoy acá
trabajando y todo me lo han acabado con
esas aguas que me echaron encima los
cultivos de aguacate también contaminan
las fuentes de agua
erosionan a los suelos y llevan a la
acaparamiento de tierras por las
multinacionales el municipio de pijao es
una zona históricamente cafetera pero
ahora cuenta con 789 hectáreas de
cultivos de aguacates El aguacate es una
mala suerte para los cafeteros de esta
región y para una tierra que además es
Sagrada es Sagrada porque esta es una
tierra fijaos una tierra de una cultura
indígena donde habitaron los pijaos por
parte los representantes de la industria
aguacatera se justifican por los números
los empleos que generan veníamos de una
crisis muy fuerte del sector caficultor
y
la industria aguacatera ha dinamizado
nuevamente la economía del departamento
que veníamos con unos índices muy altos
de desempleo y hemos aportado para que
este índice disminuya según el
Ministerio de agricultura Colombia envió
1432 toneladas de aguacates a Estados
Unidos únicamente para que estén
consumidos durante el partido del
domingo
con sombrero y a caballo así luce el
fallecido cantante mexicano Vicente
Fernández en la nueva estatua inaugurada
en su honor en Huntington Park en Los
Ángeles la escultura del rey de la
canción mexicana mide 3,7 metros de
altura y es una réplica de la que se
levanta en su tumba en el estado
mexicano de Jalisco cientos de
Seguidores del cantante acompañaron a la
viuda de Fernández en la inauguración de
esta estatua que fue aprobada en vida
por la estrella y por la Estrella
mexicana
[Música]
con estas imágenes cerramos este repase
informativo sigan conectados a France 24
y Recuerden que pueden ampliar toda esta
y mucha más información en nuestro sitio
web France 24.com
[Música]